okay this next story is simultaneously
major breaking news and completely
obvious and unsurprising to anybody
who's been paying attention yesterday
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
testified before Trump impeachment
investigators VIN Minh is this National
Security Council top ukraine expert that
has been embroiled in the Ukraine Fiasco
of Donald Trump and that July 25 phone
call and he testified that references to
Joe Biden were removed proactively from
the so called transcript of that phone
call between Donald Trump and the
Ukrainian president zalenski this is a
major claim this is a massive this is
massively important on a substantive
level but it is also exactly what any
sensible person thought was going on
from the second Trump said they were
going to be releasing a transcript Trump
called it a word-for-word transcript but
what the White House released from the
July 25 phone call was a sampling of
things that were reportedly said
remember it was a 30-minute phone call
there were about six or seven minutes of
conversation that were included in what
the Trump White House released even if
you assume that that was doubled in how
much time it took up because of live
translation back and forth for Trump and
zalenski there is still obviously a lot
missing from that phone call we knew
this the second we looked at the
so-called transcript and now Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh says this is what went
down VIN Minh says he tried to change
the transcript to include Trump telling
zalenski that there are Biden tapes for
example that was allegedly one of those
mysterious ellipses that I pointed in
pointed out in the transcript which we
believe represent removed parts of the
conversation the White House claims now
those ellipses don't mean that of course
it was not added in as we know despite
VIN man's insistence VIN Minh wanted the
transcript edited to show that Murray's
mo was mentioned the company that hired
hunter Biden he claims it was mentioned
during the call no-can-do not putting
that in the transcript we're releasing
either so let's be clear is this the
smoking gun it's not it's not and you
have Democrats and Republicans and
MinMin all saying it listen that
the general tenor of the transcript
which was really a summary is mostly
accurate but the important point is when
the subject is what was said about Joe
Biden and hunter Biden and there are
allegations that are referenced the Joe
to to Biden and a reference to the
company hunter Biden was working for
were removed it is one of many red flags
in this entire thing it's also another
analogy to the impeachment inquiry
against President Richard Nixon during
the 1970s which ultimately led to his
resignation Harvard Law Professor
Lawrence tribe mentioned the Nixon tapes
and Nixon's effort to hide the most
incriminating parts of those tapes and
you may know this you may recall if you
were around at the time or you may have
read about it there was a very
controversial eighteen and a half minute
gap that was found in one of the Nixon
tapes eventually Nixon's personal
secretary took responsibility for that
missing part saying she accidentally
deleted it and that was not a claim that
everybody believed to put it lightly the
Trump ellipses or the truncation of the
transcript that may end up being
equivalent to Richard Nixon's missing 18
and a half minutes and it is yet another
small way in which this is looking more
and more like Richard Nixon's early
1970s with every passing day is anybody
really shocked that Trump may have
committed crimes or obstruction to cover
up crimes or obstruction and once again
we find ourselves pulling out Occam's
razor Occam's razor
more really meant to be applied to
scientific assertions than the political
or cultural but I think it still applies
either Trump is lying to cover up
corruption okay or we have a Purple
Heart military veteran who happens to be
a Ukrainian double agent spy who's
involved in one of the most incredible
cover-ups ever to cover up the fact that
he is actually a spy and is making false
claims under oath about what he saw in
relation to that July 25 phone call hard
to say which is more likely oh well
Trump constantly tries to cover up his
wrongdoing and distract or suppress it
so I know
for me which is the most likely scenario
unfortunately seems like for many
trumpets they're having a hard time
figuring out which is most likely
Occam's razor seems to have been
completely thrown out the window as a
concept for trumpets as part of their
package of weaponized ignorance and
cognitive dissonance that has become
basically their operational status quo
in the trump era